I've to ever I ever told you the two
times I did stand up I don't know I do
want to hear as I did it twice twice in
my life have I done stand-up the first
time was at a bar called bins half yard
house and I don't know if you know what
a half yard house is but it is a but as
an establishment a purveyor of alcohol
that sells beer by the half yard so you
get this big glass pill it's the
stupidest thing ever to do because it's
it's giving people copious amounts of
alcohol my god
like three feet one yard equals three
feet but what so you're liking guys
realize yes the half metre it's just shy
of a meter so say 98% meter has meter
else so you go to this place and they
give you copious amounts of alcohol and
they put it in this very delicate vase
that is is handled by a baritone a tall
thin house do this down like by LA live
like where III is don't they do that
same thing there but they're probably
smart enough to put him in like plastic
things that like a toddler coddle well
yeah this was glass I mean so many of
them were broken but um anyway this was
a cross from the studio where we
recorded our first album so we were we
were over there a lot and one night we
were there and we were drinking too much
and it was a name hater like night for
for comedians and so they were doing
this stand-up and we were right there at
the stage now I had enough of these half
yards in me to feel just wildly critical
and and very vocal about it so I'm
sitting there at the front and this guy
is he's dying I mean he it is it is so
bad what he's doing he's trying but he's
not good I'm just sitting there shaking
my head and he decides this is the
moment in his set where he should do
some crowd work and he looks to me
and he goes what but do you think you
could do better and I just looked up at
him and I said brother it wouldn't take
much and the whole audience goes oh and
he hands the mic over to me now
anybody in a in the right mind would
have gone oh no no no but I took that as
oh this is Mike you grab the mic from
him see what makes me a star I mean this
is my shot and I just went off and I
started just rambling about whatever and
I did like walk in and I did just I was
it was it was when we were invading a
rock that tells you the time that we
were doing this is like there's one
person that we should send over there
right now and that's Christopher Walken
as Christopher Walken would negotiate
the best way possible
people hahahahaha so you did what comes
up to me and he goes of you I want you
back here you've got eight minutes or
whatever the designated time for a first
day of community is and we'll see you
next week and so I was like you bet
buddy I'm just gonna go throw up in your
bathroom okay so I came back the next
week and I was like here we go and I got
up on that stage and I bombed I mean I
was awful I was the worst comedian to
ever step foot on a stage and I was like
this is why I can't do stand-up unless
you're drunk and full of arrogance and I
could do it once right so like that that
that's a that's a fluke
anybody can be funny once but a stand-up
comic and I've got friends that are
really professional comedians and what
makes them so good is they've given
their lives over to this and it is a
true art form and they can do their set
it'd be terrible or awesome and they get
in their car and they drive down the
road and the next night or the following
night they do another set to a
completely different crowd and there
they're consistently funny and they can
do a time and time again and that's what
I don't have it those are my two times
that I've ever done I've done it once
and I feel like it went very well it was
a great time it was recorded and I think
it'll be published in the next few
months
however TX yes it's cheating so because
it was it RTX everyone in the crowd knew
who I was and that means that I have no
idea if any of that would work on anyone
else because they already know you as a
person the vibe is really positive
they really want to see you they're
gonna anymore you yeah like if you know
handle it a pax people will laugh at any
bad joke because they're just so stoked
to be there so I was like actually no
idea if that was good enough however I
would say that that Troy had been
drinking in the audience you would have
not I would I would say that that credit
goes to Nick Scarpino because he framed
that night well it had nothing to do
with doing stand-up it had everything to
do with people get could have been like
a rock wall in a gym it was hey here's
an opportunity for you guys to get up
here and be brave and we are going to
support you and you're working with the
net exact we're owning the fact that
everybody in this room is gonna be
effusive ly incredibly supportive of
everyone who's filming roosterteeth for
that documentary they know the one that
I did at least was off to that but yeah
Nick does have a history of like
organizing stand-up stuff auntie
basically was that was it no
roosterteeth who did like a doggy entry
of Scarpino yeah yeah yeah it's a really
by the way it's it's a it's a great doc
it's it's chronicling his the diligence
and dedication that he had to getting
his first set up at that Club in in San
Francisco but he yeah for at r-tx last
year and I did it has he done it other
times where was this the first time
twice okay so it's kind of funny stand
at night and like James and Elise
Williams gets up there and Alana gets up
there who else got up there
Blaine got up there it was a funny night
but it was it was a the the size of the
crowd was great and again it was a hot
sweaty that was like a great there is a
there is a certain I feel like I'm
dominating the conversation I apologize
yeah that's our first cold-open
this is all in the show I'm walking down
6th Street during r-tx and I just had
this I don't know if you've ever been a
place where every kind of bit of your
senses is being activated somehow by
some external thing and it
was the smell the sound the sensation
the air everything I was like man I am
in my 20s right now like this this is
how I spent so many weekends in my 20s
as a musician driving down from Dallas
going to Austin talking about being in
front of a non-supportive audience
because every everybody in Austin was
like [ __ ] Dallas bands go home because
Dallas had their music scene and Austin
had their music scene and there were
rivals but going in there and playing
those clubs and there there was just
such a palpable sensation of that summer
Texas air that like immediately took me
back 20 years it was crazy
yeah I've always wanted to DJ in Austin
just because I feel like it would be a
really fun city to do that in foot I
never found the time any time that I
visited it's always like now it's like
less than a day I mean you know Troy
it's like sometimes you fly in to do
something perversity than then leave as
soon as it's done the same day like I
did about it it's it's hectic but like
Austin what a great segue welcome to
play which listen this is a first but we
are keeping that in the show so thanks
well stand up stand up business I'm
Alanna I am joined by Austin wintry
video game composer Troy Baker video
game actor and Mike Biffle video game
director how y'all do it man so good I'm
enjoying hearing Troy's rise and fall
from stand-up grace I think the audience
got to see the kind of oh sorry go ahead
I like the audience gets to see the same
high rambling kind of conversation you
always have before we like I feel like
the bit that we release is always like
the one hour in the middle when we
remembered last week's especially I
think last week we literally recorded an
entire hour episode after finishing that
was not officially an episode because we
might play I mean we had a full
conversation that could viably have been
one of these and then was like ah [ __ ]
we should
I too wish that that was our format like
just someone said well I don't know
that's what you're supposed to do with
the turkey and there guys welcome to
what the proceeding covers oh man I feel
like we usually talk for like 20 minutes
before we publish and that's where
stuffs nd8 though so all the top secret
stories my best sort of there are a
couple of like things that I haven't
never signed NDA's for that I'm holding
on to that maybe at some point I'll talk
about like why scalebound got cancelled
but I mean yeah it's fascinating it's
super interesting but like a very large
chunk of that is just in pot that
platinum didn't think that they could
make it and xbox push them to try to
make a game on a specific engine and
platinum did not have experience with
that engine which is because I guess
Microsoft wanted to have a portfolio of
all of the different engines and I
believe it was unreal which is also what
Dead Island was on which never came out
so the assumption I'm having is that
maybe they struggle with up in wall
games I don't know that's just one is a
lot of would be dead on it in computer
oh that trailer came out and was really
good and then the game never came out
the jogging one did you do I mean the
giant the trailer that's right guys man
I don't think it was cancelled I just
kind of disappeared it just went away
yeah was it it wasn't the people I want
to make sure that I'm not telling you
maybe you guys can correct me on this I
thought that the people that did the
trailer for the first Dead Island right
the the one of the fastest game trailers
ever made which was one of the worst
game trailers that was ever made because
it was not indicative of the game at all
totally I got a whole gripe about a
whole spiel about that yeah yeah exactly
vacuum it'd have been incredible moving
through the game backwards like it was a
Christopher Nolan but and even like the
person that did the the music for that
like they they got
record deal the people got like a deal
from Lionsgate who did the trailer for
that and I think I man I want to make
sure that I'm not again telling tales
out of school but I think the people
that did the trailer for that got a game
based on the fact that they did that
trailer and it was a big game um like a
like a triple eight I was like I don't
know they just gave us his game so you
should you should do this
Wow um but even like that's the best
thing about Dead Island were those
trailers that that jogging was gay the
guy was super beat running yeah was bad
right like he's bad that's what I
remember but that I also know I didn't
finish it so I thought it was super
campy it was like this like romp you
know and the the trailer gave it like
this [ __ ] beautiful how it was that
yes I can use heartbreaking yeah yeah
soon who was that who was the composer
for that
I have no idea I mean there's so many
people in the advertising world that
option slam that's who it was
there you go if we want to get D
monetized real quick we could play it
that ruins elaborate miry Campbell Peter
Nicholson and guiya
Guido D Sarducci I don't know this guy's
name he I don't know what else do you
know Giles Lam
what he's done I mean it's probably
advertising people because there there's
a whole ecosystem of composers that do
commercials and they operate usually
either through music libraries or what
used to be called jingle houses where
they were people would be you know
marketing company is hired to produce a
an ad campaign they get bids from like
production companies those production
companies have their own relationships
with like either a full post house that
will do all sound sometimes also V
effects things like that or just a music
house that's like hey because what often
happens is they'll say look we need 10
composers to each give us a bid and so
they'll get 10 versions and then they'll
have like five of those people iterate
over and over and over and over as they
narrow it down so sometimes you'll do
Draft after Draft after Draft after
draft and then be told hey we went with
the other guy get paid for any of the
drafts most of the time yeah
advertising world tends to because it's
like unknown process that this is how
they do it there are paid demos and so
often it'll be like we'll give you a
thousand bucks for the demo process cuz
it's gonna be a lot of work but then
it's like twenty thousand if you
actually get the job so it's a pretty
substantial upgrade I mean a fine I'm
obviously drawing you know people with
more experience in than me in that
sector of the industry made correct the
numbers may not be accurate anymore
either I rarely dip my toes because I
couldn't stand how like you know I would
the notes were so insanely granular
every time I dip my toes and advertising
they'd say okay so we really like you
know the music you have on this on this
shot of like that close-up of the hand
that's nice I really feel that you know
I really feel like that's the hand but
then the next shot where it's a close-up
of like the car door I feel like we're
kind of off track there and I'm like you
know those are six frames apart and it's
the same note spanning both shots right
like it it got so nitpicky every time
that it I just thought there are people
that are wired for this better than me
like I love feedback I love like yes I
know some of the words we've been
through those this yeah it's it's
interesting going through the trailer
process we just me in Austin just have
because it's coming out Friday so we
will have released a new trailer by then
yeah for um for John we're pegs and like
the two things I found really
interesting in that process one is yes
going back to Austin's music and kind of
re-engineering some of that but the
thing that's really interesting to me
specifically in the context like the
Dead Island trailer is that trailer
houses are using engines now like in
house they're using the game engine to
make this stuff and that's been the case
for a while but it's it's it's hitting a
level of prestige in quality now that's
in
you it's not making pre-rendered stuff
they're literally booting up the game
engine grabbing our latest files and
working with stuff and kind of
essentially working as developers
they're working alongside us on their
version of the game that does all the
cool things they won't do that because
that's so that there's less dissonance
between the trailer that they're making
in the game that they're trying to make
the game trailer for yeah well I think
that's the creative reason I think the
production reason bluntly is it's
cheaper because you can just work with
what's in the game right exactly but
it's a game and that's what I want I
want trailers that represent roughly
what I can expect in the game like I
appreciate you're gonna set stuff up to
look really great and cool but but where
it gets interesting is you're getting
these this really interesting hybrid
skillset now of these trailer guys who
are in the trailer companies that we
worked with on John we used AV squad
they do they do all the job make
trailers they do all the Avengers stuff
like a big Hollywood trailer house and
but they have guys now who have come in
from the trailer side but now we're
giving them game engines and when you go
to a trailer guy and say you can choose
what shots you make for a trailer it's
like their eyes lights up with the
possibilities of that right because
they're used to just kind of working
with like here's the five VFX shots that
are finished yeah here's the here's the
shot where Robert Downey jr. looks
grizzled and has an opinion loudly and
like you have to make something out of
those parts now they're just kind of
going
I want a shot where the camera flies
past this and zooms and it can go too
far but sure but also you can kind of
have these really kind of creative
conversations on game trailers weirdly
is a very exciting area right now I
think very cool stuff yeah I would have
thought they were extremely controlled
that like trailers have thought about
for six months I have no idea how that
process works when it comes to actually
advertising the thing I know how preview
builds tend to look a little design like
for example the los preview event I
actually went to important probably the
last one I'll go to for the next yeah
was Baldus Gate three and that was they
literally they were like this is the
only part of the game that works that is
genuinely it we just have this pot
functioning we made sure I was
functioning so that's what we're showing
you it was like the part of it that they
showed us was awesome I really
appreciate when previews are really
candid about what's not walking as well
because sometimes I like games it's
broken as hell but trailers I actually
have no concept of how that comes
together all I know is the internet gets
mad when the game doesn't look like the
trailer but often that's a lot more
complicated than people
that was so much more complicated
dishonest yeah usually it's usually just
a changing direct yeah Mike do you
remember the trailer that for the last
of us that came I was only in the UK
because it was it was a ski or Soni UK
that put it out but it was the trailer
was literally a live-action trailer of a
man growing a beard progressively to
remember this yes throughout the
throughout the trailer and and then this
does this the logline ever the tagline
was could you be the last of us and it
the guy in transit he'd looked nothing
like Joel and then he went it was like
me and then all of a sudden it was
Joel's face I was like so the messaging
from this game is that you'll grow a
beard play this game well it was also I
think it was placed wasn't it in like
there was at that point that the bigger
kind of PlayStation marketing which
which I get is still which is kind of
like live another life in a game right
so like you become the character yeah
life's thing I feel like that's that
yeah like I mean that was they think
they side that like in was it ps2 era
the kind of they side that but that's
always been kind of a vibe and I think
it was kind of tight time I don't know
if that's more of a European messaging
than American men's there might be wider
trailer during the ps3 I remember
shortly after I think it was maybe
uncharted you know one or two came out
they had an ad campaign that was like a
recurring sort of character you know
like the Verizon guy kind of a thing
they had like this guy where it was all
about you know my girlfriend's sitting
on the couch and she thinks for watching
a movie I'm ready to watch the movie now
and he's putting uncharted that was
playing it yeah and they they like had a
recurring campaign built around this
idea where it would barely show the game
basically
well I've never seen that interesting is
clearly like different yeah like there
are certain games that I've been at
least family they like Wolfenstein I
really like the new order I played
through the entire design Ashley's so
good yeah it's great I placed a new
order on with my mom which was an
awesome experience cuz we would often
like pause the game and have heated
deliberations about what we were going
to do before continuing it's honestly
one of the best gaming
as I've ever had and then my favorite
game was Deadly Premonition and I think
that's also my favorite game because I
played through it in a 24-hour period
with my best friend in Australia and it
was just like who do you think committed
this crime who do you think is doing it
so just constantly discussing those
things I love a social gaming League oh
I'm late your breath of the wild that
way too at IGN we had the game five days
before everyone else and I finished it
in three I think it was like 70 hours
and three days of them that's all
possible yeah it was really hot it
wasn't sleep they were on an IV and
stuff you were like because I was
selling all the boys just sitting there
and it's like I was one to switch so I
only had the Nintendo switch console
because I was reviewing one to switch
and I would have to give the switch back
to IGN as soon as I had reviewed one to
switch that was dropping the day the
game sorry the day the console came out
so I had a really small chunk of time to
finish breath of the wild before I would
not get to play it again because I
couldn't afford a switch at the time so
you just smashed through it but it was
awesome because it was me and two other
people in the office with the only once
you had access to it and we were playing
in a room where Jose who was our lead
reviewer who now actually works at
Nintendo was playing it on a projector
and the other two of us was sitting
there with our handhelds and
occasionally he just be like don't look
up and he would like just do something
that he didn't want us to see which was
usually if he was like further ahead
than us on something really specific
will tell us to leave the room but
otherwise we were just like talking to
each other about the shrines and I wrote
this really wanky article about how I
feel like breath of the wild is a really
good multiplayer game because a lot of
the time you're talking to other people
about like what you found or how you
finished something or like what part of
the map you're on and it's just so
social despite being a single-player
game feel like I'm shot it's really good
for that to actually frankly PlayStation
does a lot of really good stuff like
that
do you guys remember the trailer that
came out it was more of a and Sony does
this a lot where is it this playstation
does this a lot I should be more
specific they'll do just kind of like
commercials for PlayStation you know
yeah they merge all their different IPS
right the best one of that was the for
Michael do you remember that one yes I
got it either if you're cold Michael yes
there was it was everybody that they had
there was a guy playing Nathan Drake
there was a guy that was playing Kratos
there was there was all of the
characters like all in this bar together
and they're all recounting their you
know war tales it was that old SNL thing
of the like firm for for what was the
like ferdowsi it was like a a John
Goodman bit of these guys sitting around
drinking about this like mythical
character that that doesn't wasn't it
kind of in that vein like yes there it
was like my know the beach I thought he
was one Alyssa goes for Michael and
they're all like for Michael I was like
that's a [ __ ] great commercial dude
just for the experience alone of being
like because that's the way that I
played ever since I was a kid like I
playing playing with my GI Joes or
transformers or anything I that the
stakes were real for me when I was a kid
and that's why when I saw Tron I was
like I knew it I knew this [ __ ] was real
like there are there are actual people
inside this game and when somebody dies
when I when I lose a life in a game that
guy dies and I I so I played very
intensely when I was a child there's
some lasting damage my date it's stuck
with me I was like I saw my last life
it's literally my last I've cried before
the goddamn as a kid yeah I was gonna
ask to any of you have experience with
like how trailers get put together
because you know this is talk to death
in the industry but for anyone you so
sugar doesn't know I do want to say like
often if you see a game trailer and it
doesn't end up looking like that on
release it's actually just that things
change in video games during development
all the time you know at this point you
know a day one patches people are making
games up until the day that they come
out so often they aren't often yeah
actually virtually every time they I'm
not trying to mislead you if a puddle is
bigger or smaller it's because every
time that you add a puddle you have to
take something else away there's only a
finite amount of space that you have
and it doesn't you can't just keep
adding puddles everywhere and sometimes
something else might be more important
than that particular puddle it's not
that they're trying to make you think
the game is full of puddles and take it
all away but I feel like a lot of people
don't quite realize how how unplanned
game development is a lot of the time I
think it's like they think that there's
a finished product months before hands
like I've seen people this week be like
why don't they just released Final
Fantasy 7 Australia already has it early
because some places shifted early to
combat potential delays because of
coronavirus like why don't they just hit
publish why don't you just make it the
digital release happen now and say
that's absolutely not how these budgets
work like your whole quarterly earnings
would be screwed if you just went on the
wrong date doesn't totally doesn't work
that way things are way more complicated
then people think but lambs is harmless
you guys know anything about about how
trailers are made like what what is the
process that goes into I mean Mike I
assume that you've made a handful yes
well yeah I have but I kind of
interesting what these guys experienced
are more where there's people who
probably have contributed to trailers
right both of you
I would assume no has it been separated
from my I mean I can I can be kind of
quick in and out on this one because I
it's it's classic it is it used to be
that back in the day a trailer of like
in the movie like in the 80s and early
90s where before the whole idea of a
trailer house was really kind of a
business the way it is now the studio's
would presume I assume they were making
their movie trailers in-house because it
was very typical that you know if John
Williams is recording the score to home
alone you know it's like early 90s they
would extract some of the score and put
it in the trailer and what you would see
in the trailer would be literally the
music from the film and then there
started to be this mid period where like
there's a composer named John Beale for
example who made a whole living of this
for quite a long time where they would
basically be hired by the trailer
company to reconstruct the score because
it might not be finished or it might not
be like eligible like for copyright or
publisher purposes to be used for batum
and so someone would be recreating this
score
then at some point trailer music started
to just become its own thing and you
have like the heavy hitters in that
world like the really famous outfit is a
is a production company called two steps
from hell that do like the kind of hans
zimmer style just to the max and they
they kind of they kind of essentially
redefined the whole trailer music
concept so that now that that's its own
that's its own genre it's its own you
know you can go on and Spotify and find
playlists of trailer music essentially
that are hugely popular because and it's
composers who do nothing but that
because they're they're so dialed into
that kind of aesthetic so speaking
specifically than from my experience
like on John wick hex that's actually on
the first trailer I essentially scored
it I I basically just wrote the trailer
music around kind of the the blocks of
the beats that were that were sort of
being outlined in the storyboard and
whatnot if I remember correctly think so
yeah I think you had like a leak out of
it but that's what it was yeah exactly
you're right yeah and then yeah that let
us refine the timing of the cut kind of
like traditional film scoring in that
way but that's very unusual most of the
time I'm just told hey you know what do
you think of this trailer and I and I
didn't even know they were working on it
and and and sushi music utterly
unrelated to the score utterly I have no
input on it whatsoever and and it's a
half the time it's like a pop song
that's just gonna say as I feel like a
water video game trail is a licensed
music yeah yeah like a lot of covers
right yeah all those in particular cuz
that cheaper because you you're cheaper
cuz you don't have to taste it yeah you
still have to pay the US as this correct
use of pay the writers publishing girls
pay performers right for this yeah the
way you don't have to get permission
also to do a cover you just you just
write basically pay and they can't stop
you and so which left it led to the
cliche right of the like moody cover of
a pop song because essentially have all
of that recognition it's
us to do that must have like really big
problem oh yeah manager was like you
saved us by the actually the I could be
wrong but the one that I think broke the
seal on that was when when Michael
Andrews I think is his name I'm blanking
but when they did the moody solo piano
cover of mad mad world for Donnie Darko
the gears of the very first Gears of War
used that in their trailer and it was
like from that point forward okay this
is all we're doing now this is the
default although I think that cover went
on to Witter like being number one in
the UK that I'm sure it's just the which
tells you everything you need to know
British people in all sense of humor
most depressing song first song that I
learned on piano really mad world the
first like pop song that I learned on
piano because of that trailer all around
me hard but yeah and thank the gears
trailers God they were good they were
just so moody I loved them so that was
the thing to the circling it back to
Dead Island I remember thinking why
isn't the game this though like they're
selling such a different experience that
at some point you just have to recognize
like at some point people just learn the
language basically and realize okay the
trailer is it's like a little short film
that the movie is figuring out what
about trailers is [ __ ] and like
that's that's an absolute thing at e3
where I like on the fly you know we have
these these press conferences and then
immediately afterwards it's like we saw
these things what do we think of them
and it is my job to be like I don't
think that game is going to be this I
think this marketing means this and I
think that one thing that's helped me a
ton as a journalist as I studied
marketing in university was part of my
degree so I feel like it's super helpful
that I can be like well they've done
that for that reason but I don't think
it's going to turn out that way the
biggest problem we're talking about this
stuff when it comes to video games as if
people are so set in what they want to
hear and I feel like that's one really
like on the consumer side or on the
marketing so on the consumer side it's a
really like complicated thing to
navigate its media because I've spoken
about this before with like Mass Effect
Andromeda I did it with days gone it's
like there are games that I can be like
I don't think this is going to be good
but people don't want to hear it so
you're you're quoting this weird space
way like well I'm gonna be honest no
matter what but the audience is gonna
hate me for being honest in this
instance so it's really complicated
thing to like am i benefiting them by
telling them that I don't think this
game is going to be what they like no
man's sky was my biggest one that I was
like I don think it's gonna be anything
to do on launch I don't think people are
gonna be satisfied with this game I'm
not convinced I that someone started a
petition to get me fired and there's
still a video you can read all the
comments of people being like stupid
[ __ ] after we talked about thank you
because the game wasn't that good holy
[ __ ] I love that game now what's so
funny is that worlds of drift
I'm giving props to my buddy I'm right
for this but I mean worlds adrift was
able to really accomplish what I think
no man's guys set out to be and I
remember that first trailer for we were
they hurt me from wrong a lot but the
first trailer they showed for no man's
sky was a PSX right yeah I remember
seeing that trailer and people stopping
me in the hallway doing interviews and
stuff they're like what do you think of
nomads skies like if they pull off what
that trailer was it is it is no pun
intended a game changer because that
just continuing to just zoom out zoom
out it was like this is like men and
black [ __ ] where it was like holy what
we are we are such a microcosmic version
of this and this thing is gonna be huge
but like worlds of dredging it did you
ever play worlds adrift no but I've
actually watched people play a lot of
thinking it is fascinating and I
remember being at Bossa studios Mike I
mean that's in your neck of the woods
did you know that I was I was the first
employee if also CEOs here's good yeah I
always forget that so you did you see
once or as Emory calls it worlds which i
think is hilarious this
imagine see the W now I like him right
so much I quit my job to go and follow
him to London to be a boss again he um
yeah I wasn't that was after I left
basically boss made a lot of like social
games and not great games and then I
quit because Thomas was alone made money
and suddenly the quality of the games
went up designed by Luke who was hired
yeah he was the designer now it's
amazingly design game and that and the
tech was impressive as well like in
terms of what they were doing
multiplayer with improbable was
phenomenal I asked him I was like I
remember them showing me like he said
this is I was like is this just like a
are you showing me a what's the verb
what's a call if you're just kind of
like a play through but it's not
obviously all recorded right they're
like no no we're actually just you're
we're opening up the lid right now and
you can see inside what's happening I
was like so all these people are playing
or like yeah he goes at this time like
GTA 5 had just got online and one of the
biggest problems were I would get online
and and my buddies that we were trying
to be we're all in different worlds
right and we're literally could be
standing next to each other in the same
place geographically on the map in GTA
but we were in completely different you
know servers had just gone no you're
over here you over here you over here
yes so I asked em Riyaz like how many
worlds do you have he was like there's
one world know when yeah yeah I get that
but I mean like like server wise he goes
no no no there's one world
I went how how are you gonna facilitate
so like the one of the point of the game
was I'll use this coffee cup if I set
this coffee cup down in the game the
world would interact with that based
upon there was a dynamic weather system
and that cup would age mold would grow
on it and if I came back a lot of six
months later to exactly where I was you
would find this dynamic asset completely
changed based upon how the world
dictated so and then you could pick it
up and UK so every every asset in the
world was dynamic it was like
I have a dream made real basically it
was yeah it was the stuff that everyone
said about fable very early on kind of
taken to its but it was real as well
like the tech world I mean Red Dead 2
does a lot of that but that came out a
lot more recently this was five years
ago six years ago no that's not you guys
anyone played Eve Eve alone yeah Mike
nailed it I I to me I'm like the over
the fence fan of Eve because I think
that that it's so it's as someone who
was hopelessly addicted to EverQuest
back in the day and then just had to
quit cuz I was like I I literally am I
have like a self-destructive that's
beautiful
came to you just enough so and I love
these large-scale events they do and
it's just like everything about it seems
so perfect and that's why I have to stay
away well I don't I tried to play it
once and was like I don't think I can do
this because I like to play a lot of
video games and that's why I aside exact
addicted to hit memos I just don't I try
not to because I could just send that
would be all I would play and then I
would miss out on everything that I have
to cover does anybody remember there was
an MMO that was uh I think it was called
Entropia it sounds familiar it was
either this was III thought it was
actually alive and you could actually
play it but if there was occurred there
was an in-game currency and this was
this would have been like eight years
ago nine years ago there's an in-game
currency that was filled by actual
dollars so you could but before loot
crate's and everything else was a thing
right so Mike you could and it was
commerce so like Mike you could have
this one got paid like a million dollars
or whatever for
or like let's say a two to $50,000
whatever was trophy thousands for a
blueprint for the code to be able to
build a spaceport hmm so in order to get
to every game development studio stream
right to be able to monetize that and so
you can have factions you know all
throughout the the game you could do
rebel or you know Imperial Alliance
whatever
so Mike builds the spaceport and then
charges people to go through it right so
a neat I'm gonna go this plan you have
to pay a toll so one of the rival
factions a saboteur gets on board of the
spaceport and people like have set up
shops you could sell your art inside
this spaceport like he made his money
back by just letting the place out but
there was a saboteur that got on and
blew up the spaceport and it was like
that's it that's some Yves [ __ ] I was
like what would you do and he goes I
would this became a thought experiment
with a group that we're talking about
he's like I would kill the guy I went
where in in the game or in real life I
was like you start you start really is
like well I guess you would have
insurance I was like holy [ __ ] you're
creating and I don't know if Eve does
this to copy pasting the real world at
that point like you're not even not even
like what's the point of even doing it
in the game like just build the real
space station and believe has emerged
cuz Eve's been around so long it has
built like there is insurance there are
there they're the one that the one that
I love and I'm sure any he found you
wouldn't even know exactly what I'm
talking about like it's probably the
cliche thing but it was a story about
one though because your rival
corporations where a corporation
literally basically did real-world
espionage different corporation did like
social engineering and stuff so they
could work they had like spies in their
corporation they basically waged a
campaign for a couple of years to kind
of infiltrate this rival corporation our
they could topple in that I bought the
history because it's genuinely it's like
it's like it's like reading actual
history absolutely things too like I
think it came out there like those
politicians a government official who is
doing illegal things and Eve in it like
very real world politician who is
basically like gaming the politics in
well like she does not so fascinating to
read about and I have so much respect
for everyone who can actually put time
into it because it's it it seems like a
very obtuse game when you first actually
look at it it's extremely complex from
like just what I've seen but the story
is a massive investment of time and
energy like I don't want to like take
part in any history but I'd love to read
it I'm not sure if it's still happening
but I know that in Final Fantasy 15 the
basically the upper class they're fine
an amount of houses that you can buy on
on service and the upper-class all the
rich players have bought out all the
houses so the poor people just Elysia
many people like post about it I'm ready
and be like this is so unfair
like how the rich just buying all the
houses like I'm in you play so I just
can't get a house now and you're like
yeah dude how does they not how do they
not see that coming a mile away that's
why we play games right so we could do
the escape the real world that's a but
that seems like a very predictable
problem I'm not right into it as much as
I should have to be able to talk about
it at length but yeah I can imagine that
they did that on purpose to create
conflict but I think there are also
complicated things where you can only
get a certain amount of items if you
have a home because you could store them
there or something like that but I mean
I'm having that with Animal Crossing
right now well like I'm just constantly
in debt and what's the name of the
little character mr. Tom no Tom no yeah
yeah raccoon dog Tom knock who to be
fair does give you interest-free loans
he's job creator he is trickle-down yes
hero he's also it's some of it's just
it's so funny that a lot of people are
playing this game that I have a memory
of Animal Crossing being relaxing but
then playing this one I'm like [ __ ]
fish got away like it because there's so
much [ __ ] that you have to manage and so
many people that you have to try to make
happy because you're trying to build an
economy and you get rewards for spending
money on the island rather than just
repaying your loans because you need to
be good to the economy it's like I don't
know even want to think about half of
this right now can I sounds like a job
this sounds like
company cinnamon Island I can you die
for the economy is that what is that
also an option to where you can just die
so that the economy could be better you
should be willing to do that now I guess
that's the I guess that's the thing I
would right before we started this or I
was saying I saw an article from someone
about how like a lot of the hardcore
long-term fans before this latest
iteration feel like the vibe is really
different and all the social media like
especially because everybody being at
home right now there's a huge amount of
sharing of like how does your island
look and there's this kind of meta
competition that has emerged of people
that like I just want to just [ __ ]
around on my island and make it cool and
now I'm like all my friends have way
cooler [ __ ] than me and I feel this kind
of inherent pressure that never was
because the game was not as pervasive
before I guess because of social media
which is kind of a bummer yeah that's
basically someone saying like I still
love the game but it's it's definitely
not like it was because it's just so
omnipresent that I feel this need to
keep up I mean I've been a little bit
like that in that like I am more of a
gym person than Animal Crossing person
so I shed a bunch of doom [ __ ]
I just kept talking about doom and
absolutely felt this wave of like
everyone so in my Animal Crossing doom
doesn't matter and I was like I will
continue to tweet about doom damn you
it's like you picked it you definitely
picked the wrong game they want to hear
about Animal Crossing that's a split in
the household between doom yeah so you
chosen our sides I feel like that is
kind of a that that's a transcendent
truth like it's we move in 24-hour
cycles right so it everyone was talking
about tiger king and then everyone
switched over now everyone's talking
about whatever it is now like III it you
can almost feel I almost feel sometimes
like I'm like BAM so far behind the
curve cuz I didn't you know interact
check this an hour ago right hour ago
he's changed I found very interesting
this week as just like a culture study
that's happened on social media is at
some point everyone decided April Fool's
Day was canceled everyone decided that
if you make an April Fool's Day joke
we're gonna be mad at you
it didn't matter what the joke was and I
fully understand where it comes from too
because it's just we don't need to give
people things to be excited about and I
call them fools right now completely get
that but it was it doesn't matter what
it was doesn't matter how you did it we
have collectively all decided that if
you make an April Fool's joke we are
going to be angry at you and I was like
it's just crazy to watch people decide
this is the cause this week if you do
that I'm on you and it's like you're
watching people just throw all their
energy into this thing before it's even
happened knowing that if anyone does it
there's gonna be a consequence and so
many people jumping on it like that just
like trying to get these tweets to get a
ton of retweets because other people are
doing it is like watching that happen
and it's not like this is a week where
all of the marketing teams who set these
things in motion like weeks ago they're
all like struggling just like the rest
of us right so they might not have the
time or the resources to like to cancel
whatever they were doing free probably
the stuff Paul's there I do
sorry there April Fool's coverage down
or refused to do it like Google and the
employees who are working on that stuff
are so devastated because they had
something that was fun and silly today
were going to do that the internet
decided they were not allowed to no
matter what it was it was just you're
not allowed like you say though in a
couple of hours right like that decision
was made yeah by the collective yeah it
was just really interesting to watch
like I feel like plus rules so much more
online right now right as well so
definitely plays into those kind of
things yeah I think it speeds up that
cycle a ton because everybody has a way
now what now what now what do mala ji I
can't stand the the like outrage of the
hour where it's it's it's never
principled or I shouldn't say never but
it's very often these things are like
just because it catches fire and it
achieves this critical mass where the
social consequence of being a contrarian
outweighs anything else and so it was
like it was well I guess I was going to
depend on if Alana and Troy agree with
you yeah it's it's I think a lot of the
time with social media it's people
jumping on causes that they don't
necessarily care about a lot of the time
to feel like they're doing something in
full and I understand that to when so
much of the Internet is screaming into a
void and feeling like you want to it's
like I understand both sides of that and
like yesterday I was a huge people for
hours because that's a like a thing that
I've started doing more since quarantine
is just replying the things I normally
wouldn't and I shouldn't be like I
caught myself yesterday nice
I just keep arguing with these people
because I why because I'm at home I
think because I'm frustrated genuinely
if like I'm gonna psychoanalyze myself
it's because my family's in Australia
and I feel like the whole world is being
pieces of [ __ ] when my stepdad on my dad
have both had to go to hospital
repeatedly for cancer my dad had surgery
last week they didn't get all the cancer
so he has to go back in four weeks I'm
like you [ __ ] keep walking around
outside and my dad gets sick when he
goes to hospital I'm but in the wall
down so I think that's what's happening
is that I feel very angry at everyone so
I'm just arguing people who to be fit
arguing with me first
it's just that I'm engaging what I don't
we wouldn't but yesterday is the thing
right that little that read that control
that we all have to have as people who
are public and you know representing
various different things listen I'm not
dark saying I'm mostly just arguing
about it but yesterday I did it with I
tweeted I thought it was pretty harmless
that I felt like right now specifically
is a bad time to release a 1-month time
to exclusive game regarding the modern
warfare 2 campaign can we do PlayStation
3 days before anywhere else which cuz
you can't go on buy a new console yeah
and I mean it's it's like I'm not a huge
problem in it it's already on Xbox one
because this backwards compatible but
you know this is a new thing and it's
just right now specifically I don't feel
like we should be releasing time to
exclusives but they would have already
signed a contract it would have already
been yeah yeah this is just business but
I just ended up getting into arguments
of people about how it's good for
PlayStation game is actually and it's
like pro-consumer and it was just like I
don't like it sometimes watching people
defend companies blindly because it's
part of their identity even though it's
not actually good for them and
exclusives I'm not actually good for the
public they're only good for the people
who make the hardware there's a whole
itical thing though too whole thing the
the the tooth first of all to comment
briefly on that I was there was nobody
was more excited about the modern
warfare 2 remastered than me I was like
holy [ __ ] I can't believe they're fun
this has been rumored for so long
they're smiling and I'm excited to play
the campaign however that
was not my favorite part of that game I
miss playing those maps and I especially
miss the spec ops missions like I wanted
so badly to do the sniper missions like
I was so looking forward to those sniper
missions it was a great thing that I
could do with my friends or so that I
could do by myself that just was a small
microcosmic version of that game that I
could play very quickly and the fact
that they didn't support that I totally
understand it's a big undertaking to try
to go we're not going to support this
server wise right they're not gonna
delegate servers for people to go back
and play in water more for to
multiplayer and the spec ops is a very
small thing so we're not gonna upper as
all that we're just simply going to
focus on the campaign and put that out
because we could do that very cheaply I
understand it so I kind of like got my
excitement level and ran a little bit
but Alana for you the question that I
have is I understand the reason why I
engage in argue and especially at a time
right now where I like you said you want
to have impact you want to have control
I don't feel like I could control my
world right now but I can control this
or try seemingly control this
conversation with 280 characters do you
feel on the other side of it especially
because you're you are where and I
really commend you and applaud you for
being able to go I'm doing this because
of this and this is my outlet I'm not
mad at the punching bag but I do
understand and make the connection that
my level of frustration is somehow
impacted by me putting this fist against
this piece of plastic do you on the
other side of that argument do you feel
better do you go okay I've made my point
about doom to this asshat you know you
know chicken [ __ ] 99 or whatever his
pursuers her name was on Twitter do you
feel better on the other side of it or
do you feel worse I don't want to answer
I think I might it might make me feel
better but I don't want that to be the
answer because I do it in a small stand
where I'll like argue people on one
tweet for two hours and then leave it
and it's also that the volume of
negativity that I get as a woman with
opinions on the Internet is extremely
high so a lot of it I ignore all the
time
and even without an opinion I've noticed
like even if anything when we're tagged
in the Tweety I will just see a bunch of
random [ __ ] like if this is what she's
getting on no it's constant it's like
you know like a few hundred negative
comments a day right and I for the most
part of my stuck out whatever but I feel
like once you get a certain volume of
that not engaging in any of it is like
sometimes I just have to be allowed to
stand up for myself like sometimes I
just have to be allowed to do that and
I'll always get replies little like
don't engage that makes me more mad than
whenever I'm engaging with usually
because I'm like you have no idea what
this is like like for people who deal
with this stuff on a large scale they
have to have an outlet sometimes and
sometimes an outlet is just calling an
idiot an idiot and then walking away
like letting it all wash of you is just
stressful it's just a lot of pressure
and like at some points in time I'm like
I just have to be able to tell someone
when I think they've been a [ __ ] and
then I'll be like stump alright I'm just
way do you feel like though however by
it by engaging with them
I have no opinion either way which is
the point of this is that it's just
opinion but do you feel that by engaging
that that there is credibility that is
given to that person or to their opinion
I don't think about like a not really
but I do it for me more than I do it for
the other person so if I feel like I
need to call someone an idiot sometimes
I'll do it and you know people will be
like well if you give them attention and
they're maybe that's what they wanted I
don't care what they want it like
because this is what I wanted and I need
to do something to feel better as well
if they're allowed to do it I'm allowed
to do it but then it's also people will
say well if you do it once what people
be more likely to do it and that's not
true because there was one time I time
the literal month rose like I'm not
gonna engage in any negative comments I
got the exact same amount it doesn't
matter what I do they throw it at me no
matter what so it's it basically is like
my approach to dealing with massive
amount of negativity on social media is
literally what will make me be able to
get through this because if I think if I
didn't engage in any of it I'd probably
be off social media by now because I
just be like stop [ __ ] policing
everything I do and sometimes I just
have to yell at someone to be like stop
[ __ ] policing everything I'm doing a
lot last follow-up to that is do you
think that lets say okay I don't like
you said is very again a very aware
thing too
I don't I don't care what they're
getting out of this I was like oh good
they got their attention like that the
snow I'm doing this I'm doing this so
that I can cathartic ly get rid of my
[ __ ] and and feel better on the other
side do you think that person the
recipient of that on the other side is
better or worse if I can frame it in
that binary way for that response
fifty-fifty because sometimes people
will reach out to me afterwards like I
get a lot of comments probably of people
being like hey I was really awful to you
several months I'm sorry and I've never
done it again and I won't remember what
they said but it happens all the time
people because it's a really bad [ __ ]
about you and I want from that
experience but then sometimes they just
like lose their mind feel vilified and I
think like part of that comes with you
know if I reply to someone negatively
then 30 other people do and then they
don't expect it and my argument that has
always been well if you're engaging with
me then and saying something negative
and I'm not allowed to reply but you're
allowed to say it you should know when
you're engaging with me but that that
could happen and that's a choice than
you lying when you said some share to
someone who has four hundred thousand so
we're like 50% Spider Man 50% joke too
much you know I'm not going to recommend
I don't think that I'm particularly mean
to anyone because all I ever do is I
don't I never call anyone names I don't
calling that profiles they don't
actually say anything about them I will
only ever argue with the individual
thing that they have said not anything
personal I don't do any of that but
sometimes it's just you're all about the
dry sarcasm and like snarky detached
yeah sort of like I would never want to
debate with Alana Pierce I would never
want to be in the situation where I had
to be in opposition it's a you all are a
person who's incredibly intelligent and
whose opinions that are strong are
equally informed so you and you are and
I debate constantly on things and that's
the thing but I think is like in a
healthy way yeah really good like we
would just have a conversation and we
disagree on points but we're both coming
from different perspectives that are
both educated so I actually loved
I want to bait you so hard right now
back down that it's a problem and I
don't think I'm generally stubborn about
most things there's some things that I
will be stepping on like health care but
just like this weird like I feel like
we're in a really strange landscape
because everyone is online and it's also
even the conversation about coronavirus
has changed a lot in the beginning mmm
I made a video about how a lot of games
are probably gonna get delayed because
of it and I got a lot of comments saying
like how dare you talk about this people
are dying that conversation that has
gone for some reason and I suspect what
happened is that like now you're allowed
to talk about every aspect of it and
nobody's mad I feel like it was
originally because it was so isolated it
was people very signaling a little bit
and now that everyone's dealing with it
and it's a reality people do want to
understand every aspect of it as well as
someone who was quite kind of I was one
of the the early nerds who was like the
one in my group who was going on about
this like before I think oh yeah
seriously Mike and there are so many
podcasts that have been up where you
have audio bytes of people being like
it's it's not a big deal is he's so
dominum like thank God for Mike that's
it and I think that might be what's
shifted genuinely is that people like me
who were like I said this to my
girlfriend like about a week ago it was
when the when the lockdown happened in
the UK it was you know obviously
everyone was kind of having there was a
horrible moment and it's terror it's
scary and all this stuff and I was kind
of happy and it was this weird moment of
like no I'm happy because everyone's
taking this seriously I suddenly feel
like I'm not a crazy person wrote I
suddenly feel like the world's kind of
yeah and this isn't me kind of showing
off ready it's it's more just kind of
there's a comfort from knowing that
everyone else is now take you seriously
I wonder if that's what where the will
you're describing comes from I'm on
because maybe it was the people like me
who were like we stop talking about this
nonsense we've got to you know save the
world
yeah and now I think because of people
like me are a bit calmer now because we
know everyone's taking it seriously now
we now it's maybe a bit more comfortable
start having those time zones because it
feels like a while is taking its
Leigha for the most part are no longer
just you know I'm not chicken little
anymore and it actually feels quite nice
to have to know that there's a consensus
to know that people are taking it
seriously yes yes two issues la I left
the apartment for the first time in two
weeks yesterday
that's IIIi if I can encourage you I was
in the same place and it get just
getting outside and reminding myself
there's still a Sun in the sky there's
still clouds are still blue and and that
was incredibly healthy for me and I feel
like the needle can go far the other way
too and what has been revealing for me
about this situation is that I
originally was like alright everybody
calm down because I can be a pragmatist
but I can also be a fairly buoyant
optimist and and not go it was such a
culturally I couldn't wrap my head
around culturally we I'm no stranger to
adversity and and and the atrocities of
life and people dying and I've lived
through Wars I and I understand it but
it was the cultural impact it was like
that happens in other countries it
doesn't happen here was very it was very
revelatory of how comfortable I had
gotten in my own routine and my own cozy
cozy
you know white bread life and Pam and I
both have been like now we're gonna be
hardcore about this and we have David
who's our own assistant and I was like
David you can't be here and it's hard to
look at your two-year-old son and go I
know you want uncle Dee here but he
can't be here right now and so we
FaceTime with them we've made hard lines
and it's some of our neighbors look at
us like are crazy because we're like
came out I'm sorry we didn't we talked
across the street but we're really
taking this seriously because we know
people that are in the healthcare system
and we know what they're doing and
somebody put up that wonderful video of
like let me show you what it looks like
for this guy to go to work and the
amount of precautions and measures that
they take to not only keep themselves
from getting sick but from preventing
other people from getting sick
and stupid slide basically yeah they
like you put things on their face and
it's the mass ins the duct tape then is
the shield then is the taping this whole
thing up and all the the stupid thought
that occupy my prayers like dude what if
you see that the bathroom that sucks
you have to go through all of that so
then you think is like we only have one
of these per day like so many of those
health care people uh only have one mask
and they only have one gown so it was
like you hold it [ __ ] all day
long and I am bored no my job is to stay
home right now that's that's that's what
I can do so it was a it was a big wake
up call and I'm and Mike you were so I
was like I everybody calm down it's like
no remember the conversation I remember
being a bit frustrated by the
conversation if I'm on this no III dude
this has been a really good well I get
where you're coming from and it's scary
I think the I think the optimistic thing
for me in all this what I like to think
of in this is I wonder if as a society
we're learning how to solve problems
that are very big I feel like we we've
never humanity is not designed to deal
with kind of big existential threats
very often we're not very good at it and
our generation like like you say the
wars have been far away you know or
they've been where they've there's been
a distancing that's happened we can
change your chair or feeling like
especially as I do about kind of
environmental stuff and those problems
that are coming down the road I wonder
if this is to an extent like a rehearsal
if we're all gonna learn a lot about how
to deal with problems they're much
bigger than arson our neighbors and
we're gonna start to actually understand
how society works a bigger level I think
maybe that's the lesson in this and I
think I think that's that's that's how I
that's what I try and you should remind
myself all do you feel unified in a way
that I haven't seen before right because
we see how connected we are as like this
person came from this place whatever
this place and infected everything just
by the nature of doing their normal life
this is what doesn't Mandy has wanted to
squid this is what he was going for
Ozymandias yeah this is what he was
trying to make happen
it was hard do you know what's great is
literally carry my girlfriend turned to
me and said that was we were walking
down the street the other day she's like
this was what the squid was about this
is absolutely what the squid was about
yes give me your I'm curious your take
on this because for me it's interesting
how on in one way things be united but
also things through another lens to me
feel in far more intensively polarized
and ideological because the mayor of LA
put out an announcement that as part of
their effort to keep people at home and
to just do their part they said we are
going to shut off water and power to
businesses we design we deemed
non-essential in the city of La and her
privately that really pissed me off
because I thought first off that's a
very that's a very like if your goal is
to try to calm people down and and and
reassure them and sort of do that aspect
of leadership big fail there I also
understand the need for a slightly
draconian even approach on the part of
certain leaders and I don't and I don't
like in total resonance with everything
that you're saying especially Troy about
like let's take this seriously totally
support that and I I obviously I think
no one you know I you won't find any
disagreement from me the thing that so
but I shared that article on the kind of
press release online and I said for a
population full of people that are
scared how is this a helpful measure
especially because aren't there like
security alarms and [ __ ] that are tied
in with these pact like what this was
such an ill-conceived press announcement
all I was saying is does this feel like
a good strategy also side note I don't
work from home I don't have to interact
with a single human being to come to my
studio it's such a short my car could
have I could walk it first off but I
don't even need to do that it's such a
short distance I have months worth of
gas in my car necessary to make that
drive like I felt somewhat like clearly
my business would be considered
non-essential but it's a big
it's a big undertaking to move all my
[ __ ] home and and and to what end like I
I get Agri - what would you know help
your house to your office like yeah I
get that you know I can't complain if
I'm an outlier and it just because it
applies to me in this esoteric way it's
not gonna apply to everyone now I have
total sympathy for that but I the only
reason I'm bringing this up is not to
hash that out but I I wrote online like
surely I don't count as essential but
does that mean I'm just screwed I'm just
I'm just curious basically to me it's a
dispassionate open question and the
amount of victory all I got from people
that were like stay the [ __ ] home you
selfish [ __ ] and like I think that I
that's why they've done it is not to
calm people down it's for people who
aren't like you who aren't causing
problems who are still going to walk and
not caring I would guess that like the
reason they've done that is not to make
people calm it's because I just didn't
understand why I got attacked by by
friends of mine even like people that
I've known for years who came after me
as if I was just advocating murder I was
like it was bizarre to me where I
thought this has become ideological in a
way that is bizarre to me because this
is if I think that's a cultural that's a
really interesting cultural difference
I've discussed with like American
friends over the last few weeks is I
think I'm treading very carefully
because I want to get this right but I
think that there is a big cultural
difference between Europe and America on
this stuff and I'm not saying Europe oh
there are lots of examples where we've
gone wrong with all of this round
America has solved its problem oh yeah I
think we might be you're like fur I feel
like for this I feel you're very
European feel like we should be my guess
my point is I'm America has solved its
problems rightly some of those problems
by the way were British many of them
through freedom and independence and and
individualism but not meanness like but
just knowing - like going going for and
having individual liberty should we say
for all yeah almost isolation like
there's history in Europe in the UK
like we're very used to and it's
culturally ingrained in a way that we're
very used to kind of keep calm and carry
on
I mean that the history of outside I
know if you guys know that that was
literally a sign that was manufactured
for the occurrence of if we were invaded
by Nazi Germany it was a sign that was
going to be put up big well you know
just to keep calm and carry on in the
face of Nazi oppression that's the
British kind of attitude that was that's
the origin they were posters that were
made up and they were ready in a
warehouse in a stockroom the presumption
was those my mind and then but I think
there's a cultural kind of I just love
their likes a church he'll like like
those ads for the the Gary Oldman it's
like you know you don't reason with a
tiger when your head is in its mouth but
if they wear is it
keep calming very odd I mean that's the
cultural there was I mean that the Nazis
hello numbers the Nazis there are books
that they they or like they they they
planned out the invasion of the UK and
they essentially their notes on the UK
was written fold in an hour basically if
they still got the royal family in place
then they'll just go along and they'll
be kind very quickly do you remember
there was a there was a terrible fog
that I think took place and someone came
to Churchill and said do you understand
that the loss of life that will happen
it was it was a catastrophic time do you
know do you know the story that I'm
talking about I it's ringing a bell but
carry on that it was someone came too
late did you understand that where they
it shut the city down like it was so bad
that that the ships couldn't come in and
people were told to stay home and that
the loss of life was gonna be something
like a hundred fifty thousand it was it
was just terrible and Churchill knew
going in that this is what it was going
to take and and he was like this is what
it means to be Prime Minister is that
I'm gonna have to own this decision and
that I'm doing everything that I can to
just keep this keep this traffic forward
but he had to shut the city down before
and there was still a tremendous loss of
life it's horrific but I think there's I
do remember one but it was I think
there's yeah I think I know I don't I
don't basically to come back to what
Ralston was saying I think the
point I'm making is that I feel like the
ideological debate is a very particular
to America one I don't hear that
happening over here I think here the
discussion is should we just carry on
because because because for many British
kind of successes in these kind of
situations it's been about just going
about your life don't let the terrorists
win as a mentality and that really
doesn't work against disease um so
that's the debate here is like do we go
on with normal life or do we stop and
it's not borne out of the kind of the
government shouldn't tell me what to do
kind of discussion so I feel like it's a
very polarized issue specific to the to
the politics of America right I think I
would agree with that I think the
Australian stance would be more like the
European one in this instance the
culture is very different man we have to
let Troy go yeah yeah I don't know what
I'm gonna title this episode oh my god
so good this has been a rumble House me
I would also push us and you and I can
talk offline pushing against that
definition of or the the invocation of
the word stoicism for that I would say
that that's not stoicism but that's I
could be I could be using it wrong also
well not not likely not not knowing you
you know I don't I don't I I mean that
earnestly I mean sometimes I just I just
get something in my head the wrong way
and it takes five years of me doing it
wrong before somebody's like you know
that's really not what that means I
don't know what to suggest calling this
but it is Troy's birthday we should add
is that is that is not a I would want to
make anybody mad that is not an April
floss yes forty before on the floor for
yeah Matt forty-four pound row make it
is I mean not if you actually spelled it
out that it would be like rowf rowf but
I mean that's not really myself the last
few days has been tough and I feel like
part of it is that I'm struggling with
continuing to make content for fun house
and I'm trying to make more on my
personal channel to give people a
release and in all of that I am avoiding
talking about anything negative because
I feel like I'm trying to get people in
a
scape and I think that's doing my head
in is that I'm just like nope I'm just
gonna talk about things that let people
like just think about video games for an
hour and I think the fact that I'm doing
that and and just ignoring problems so
other people don't have to hear problems
is absolutely having an effect on me in
some weird way
so I appreciate my problems I needed
that this week well let's let's call
this episode the Festivus airing of
grievances then titles what my youtube
who cares SEO and that what I love also
though by the way is that you Alanna
have a great pitch for us to talk about
that now I think no real besides in a
row we have not touched it I love that
it's gonna be great when we get that
next was a little easier but it's so
true I love that we've managed to anyway
please don't neglect your outlet of
toxicity Ilana actually I know but I say
that because I really deeply to that
because like Troy I also am a pretty
optimistic person but I do I have had
periods in my life where it was really
bad and also on a micro level like you
store that [ __ ] like like venom if you
if you don't have a way to kind of
release totally yeah I think for the
most part I deal with it super well and
I'm totally fine and like everything's
okay it's it's just this past week is
I've just been like but I think it is in
very large part because my dad has been
in hospital which Mansa and I'm like
maybe I should just not be on the
internet while I'm dealing with that
from another country that I can't leave
don't shout out to my dad love you I
hope you think he's gonna be alright
soldiering through yeah cancer sucks but
you know answer sucks [ __ ] cancers yeah
he's both counts the [ __ ] virus about
all of it and bless video games also
McDonald's documentary series on HBO I
think it's called a good with millions
right at [ __ ] yes
it's very interesting shout out to that
also we have wild fantasy in resident
evil 3 very hot coming out this week
slash not next week so I'm excited about
both of those two mmm
can't wait for next week we finally
talked about what allows no need to talk
about all right happy birthday Troy and
we'll see you guys next week
they